je ne sais pas si c'est pas nous c'est
que j'ai pu lire dans lui alain servi en
salle d'art dit
dan que la plus difficile quels sont les
défauts nicola sirkis que doit avoir une
femme pour vous séduire une vaginite
aiguë avec pertes blanches sur l'inconnu
ça serait bienvenu que la rue pour les
inconnus se serait bien vu la suite qui
vous a fait le plus plaisir
si c'est une insulte sûr qu'on me dise
de moi [ __ ]
ouais ça me fait plaisir vas-y moitié
des téléphones ou non sa note nicolas le
compliment qui vous énerve le plus il
est trop gentil où il est gentil
ouais mais c'est vrai que les gentils en
même temps je sais non mais c'est vrai
que tu es janvier je sais moi j'ai
rencontré l'autre soir j'ai dans un truc
m'a dit deschamps
il est pas gentil il est patient c'est
pas pareil c'était pour sa fille il
voulait un autographe pour pas de mon
père pour sa fille parce que sa fille
n'aime pas de chinois sans cesse le
calvaire qui pourrait être celui qui m
m voilà et mais elle a eu sa période
mais son petit ami m indochine ans un
copain m'a dit que c'était son petit ami
à un ibérique mais vous lire
alors le conseil de nos parents qui
veulent faire des casses il fait
confiance aux grandes personnes
le disque que vous avez honte d'avoir
acheté ou alors c'est pas contre la
chanson mais ni l'artiste c'est lolita
d'alizée
mais en fait c'est parce que on voulait
le reprendre on voulait reprendre la
chanson je voulais la faire à ma façon
je m'appelle nicolas lycées où est la
messagerie group sa a pas plu du tout du
tout donc ces ultimes l'idée que vous
aimeriez qu'on vous vole une idée fixe
une obsession oui pour quelles raisons
seriez vous capable de refuser votre
plus belle histoire d'amour bas que ce
soit la femme de mon meilleur ami remis
par exemple ouais tu vas lui ça ferait
pas la femme ne peut excuser pour ta
femme c'est bon le talent que vous ne
riez pas avoir nicolas videur dans une
boîte échangiste clair aussi la mauvaise
chanson que vous auriez aimé chanter à
pas mal de chansons populaires que vous
êtes fier de ne pas avoir chanté par
principe un hymne national ouais ils
paraissent marc racine passe par
principe nicholas pard qui aimeriez-vous
être détesté voix par des vieux cons
voir des jeunes cons comment il nous
parle
la dernière question qu'il ne faut pas
que je vous pose est-ce que ça va voilà
mais c'est une question que je vous la
pose et voilà